tengo el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón danny buena
noche es bienvenida la economía de eeuu
recuperó el nivel pre pandemia ahora
raúl mire en el segundo trimestre de
2021 el producto interno bruto de ese
país creció 65 por ciento frente al
mismo período del año pasado y 1,6 por
ciento si se compara con el trimestre
anterior
esto pone al tamaño total de la economía
en su nivel anterior a la pandemia y
convierte esa recesión en la más breve
de su historia
con los datos de hoy la economía de eeuu
ha recuperado las pérdidas de los
últimos 18 meses y ha superado el pico
del pib pre pandémico de hecho en la
primera mitad de este año la economía
creció a la tasa más alta en casi 40
años pasaron dos años después de la
última recesión para volver al nivel
anterior hoy tomo la mitad de tiempo de
hecho
daniela pero no sólo está no sólo eeuu
porque méxico también dijo estar cerca
de recuperar su economía sí señor lo
dijo la secretaria de hacienda y crédito
público de méxico que aseguró que la
actividad
económica ya está al 99 6% del nivel pre
pandemia y que el empleo está al 98 8%
tras la primera mitad de 2021 en efecto
hasta junio pasado se habían recuperado
12,3 millones de empleos formales un
promedio de 880 mil puestos al mes desde
marzo de 2020 que fue cuando iniciaron
las restricciones por el coronavirus y
el desempleo ya está en un 4 por ciento
desde el 35 por ciento pre pandémico
pero raúl no hay que olvidar que el
problema laboral más grave de este país
está en la informalidad que afecta a más
de la mitad de los trabajadores como
muchos lugares también de américa latina
daniel a la polémica aplicación robin
hood tuvo una decepcionante salida de la
bolsa pues raúl usted recordará que esta
aplicación que permite a miles de
principiantes negociar en bolsas sin
intermediarios fue protagonista del
polémico caso gamestop pues ahora se
lanzó a wall street' este jueves lo hizo
con bombos y platillos veamos el mercado
de valores en particular ha sido una
gran fuente de creación de riqueza para
muchas
ha estado reservado para el 1% durante
mucho tiempo por lo tanto estamos
orgullosos de brindar acceso y hacerlo
más fácil de usar para todas las
personas le voy a refrescar la memoria
raúl mire un grupo de miles de pequeños
inversionistas que usaron foros como
redes y aplicaciones como robin hood
hizo disparar la acción de algunas
empresas entre ellas gamestop y a su vez
les hizo perder miles de millones de
dólares a los gigantes de la bolsa de
nueva york estos mismos grandes
inversores parecen haberle cobrado
factura e hicieron que la acción cayera
un 8 por ciento en su debut algo que
raramente sucede en un estreno bursátil
y pongámoslo en números su valoración de
mercado perdió unos 3000 millones de
dólares apenas en una jornada de dolor
daniela como una heladería se rebeló
contra un gobierno pues mire la
estadounidense wenn and jerry's es
quizás la heladería que hace mayor
presencia en israel pues concentra el
75% del mercado premium en ese país hace
unos días sorprendió con el anuncio de
que dejara de vender sus productos en
territorio palestino
a partir de 2022 y el argumento es que
lo hace por incompatibilidad con los
valores de la compañía hoy en día más de
600 mil colonos israelíes viven en
cisjordania y jerusalén del este en
donde a menudo se enfrentan con la
población palestina estos asentamientos
son considerados ilegales por naciones
unidas y por la comunidad internacional
pues organizaciones de derechos humanos
han denunciado reiteradamente la
actividad comercial en estas zonas de
hecho amnistía internacional denunció
que operadores turísticos como el bembé
o tripadvisor y booking ofrecen planes
para ir a estos territorios el anuncio
llegó al plano político el primer
ministro israelí naftalí bennett
calificó a la firma como una heladería
antiisraelí y lo mismo hicieron varios
políticos
danielle indicadores o escritos volvió a
las ganancias después de conocerse los
datos macroeconómicos del segundo
trimestre y después de que siguieran
conociéndose resultados financieros
amazon por ejemplo duplicó sus
beneficios entre enero y junio y en
latinoamérica la bolsa de méxico acumuló
ocho sesiones al alza y la de buenos
aires- cuatro sesiones para finalizar
que nuestra como cifra el día 1.5
millones de empleos formales que generó
brasil en el primer semestre aunque el
desempleo se mantiene en niveles récords
cercanos al 15 por ciento
danny como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica a ustedes también
gracias continúa con nosotros
[Música]